private counsel in cheating the system
news submitted by Jamal Ian duriandurian
a lover named rich families legally
separated from their kids in newly
discovered ways they've milked the
college oh that's genius that's genius
so then they could qualify for fine yes
is that what that is
exactly whoo-hoo-hoo damn it could you
can't divorce your parents or emancipate
roll sale no no no I think they'd get
rid of their kids and put them somewhere
else need another family no he's talking
about him in the mat-su okay or it's
either emancipating or actually both of
you are right I'm holding another
guardian we combined forces yeah do you
guys see this as a moral issue
yes that's lying well but then it was
not like this was quickly yeah the
parents don't get a tax write-off on the
children anymore if they don't have
dependents how much all are they really
winning and how much financial help for
the kids getting parents what's find out
what's the point of financially it's for
for free money
yeah the moral whom free money for
everyone no well I mean but it was it
targeted for the reap to reach for the
rich people oh I Suzanne yeah all I ask
you is for me yes that's for the it's
for people that are underprivileged I
can go to school it's people that want a
new set of rims for the car no or a
pound of marijuana no but that's what we
did use it for yeah this is how rich
people get rich as they find loopholes
like this illegal they're not yeah you
did and I'm like yeah that's [ __ ] up I
think I'll be sitting down I'd be
sitting in my movie theater surrounded
by all my friends and we're having like
a party with caterers and [ __ ] that we
treat like [ __ ] and I'd be like yeah I
guess being immoral really sucks
yeah this was discovered when a guidance
counselor a high school guidance
counselor called an admissions director
at the University of Illinois to ask why
specific students had been invited to an
orientation for disadvantaged kids so
that's when the director looked into it
and found that this this high schooler
had legally emancipated herself from her
parents
and this whole process the emancipation
process it's generally for people or
like for kids that are in abusive homes
that they need to just get away from
their kit their parents and they can
sustain themselves on their own and not
have to be under the legal guardianship
of their parents there's a parent's but
the way that these rich people are doing
it now apparently this has been linked
to this place called destination college
which offers private counseling all
right [ __ ] beat is blue like right
away that's how you react to a fly fly
whatever the [ __ ] it was they like
wasn't [ __ ] their future - I literally
felt like I've been having trouble
breathing about that that [ __ ] thing
is out for me I thought you were about
to go back in time that's just a fly
like Noah's right cuz he you know is
loud whatever I'm you have ninja-like
reflux you know what that tip never gets
the floor where she's not interrupted
and finally everyone will leave in on
the average podcast as soon as they get
the flip some [ __ ] are up to no matter
what universe that they want you to say
what you have to say that fly has been
with us since we did the patriotic look
would you gotta check it out
patrons go check it out I don't think I
would have gone as scared if you didn't
physically title me know what it was
always being out back I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry okay no are you okay though
it's just a fly dude what if it was a
bee Jesus Christ
sounded like one in my ear I didn't know
the difference would you have stripped
naked and [ __ ] ran through a wall
no okay yeah what'd she do I just felt
it you'll see it the video later video
guys I want to see what happened anyway
what was I saying
were they in the middle of you're
talking about what it's been linked to
so you you named a destination college
whoo yeah they offer private counseling
yeah thank you trying to help parents
and helping their kids get into colleges
and [ __ ] and they have like strategies
it so they were helping him be immoral
pretty much but it's not illegal you're
not a way to game the system but
unfortunately it's these people that are
privileged yeah able to pay the extra
and have these outside I'm gonna talk
even slower cuz I know you want to speak
right now so so if they so I have
nothing against them if like the they
are coming from like an unfit a family
and they're like [ __ ] your parents I
want to do it on my own and now they've
been completely cut off I'm cool with
that
yeah but if they're like still not cut
off and the parents are just bawling out
rich kids can have bad parents it's not
a mall to me sometimes they get their
pockets filled money that's too heavy
they can't walk around it is [ __ ] up I
wonder how rich they are cuz if they're
really rich the parents would be like
[ __ ] it
yeah they don't even need to find a
loophole fit yeah this just sounds like
middle-class people who can afford it no
but there's some rich people that just
want to stay rich and they want to pipe
in dude I heard that build a team I
heard that Bill Gates pays exact change
when you go someplace really you never
know who's gonna be weird
a pay phone in his house um there you go
if I was Bill Gates I would just
probably only have hundred-dollar bills
yeah so this one example here is that
this this one girl her family's
resources she said that her family's
resources were tapped out despite living
in a 1.2 million dollar home in Illinois
by the way and she said that but ballin
is Fuzz probably a 10 million dollar
home in California yeah like they had
been earning more than two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year yeah she
ended up transferring her daughter's
guardianship to her business partner
using legal methods but her business
part is broke so she qualifies for
financial aid what ended up happening is
that the daughter only had to claim her
income from a working summer job and so
she received a $20,000 financial aid
package yeah which is including a
federal subsidy meant for needy students
known as a Pell Grant and they were able
to cover the rest of her $65,000 tuition
through a combination of scholarships
and help from the grandparents so this
girl obviously had money and her family
who can help her but yet she's still
taking these grants that are meant for
250k year is not that crazy I was
expected to hear way more now that's
what I was saying they're probably just
upper middle class and they can't afford
it but then they're trying to figure out
a way to make their money stretch you're
talking about a joint income to like two
parents yeah together is two hundred
thousand and here's a single mom with
two hundred grand but I guess I guess
the moral issue now is that they're not
they're not the target audience they're
not the money taxpayers more then yeah
it's to help you know social what do you
call it mobility yeah yeah yeah the
upward movement and I get that I just
don't it's just like when I hear that
they're gonna be rich as [ __ ] I didn't
expect that well a lot of people's idea
of rich is kind of skewed right like
because I mean what well I think you
know I look up like billionaires and all
that those guys are really [ __ ] rich
like and then you see what and also in
LA like upper middle class in LA is a
millionaire Yeah right yeah cuz it all
depends on the
living I think so I guess when they're
living they are consider bridge yeah it
also depends like if she's a business
owner making 200 grand that's very
different from a car salesmen making 200
grand
yeah that it there's a lot of yeah I
mean yeah there's all these like [ __ ]
little my new details but I think
ultimately if this stuff is supposed to
be for low-income and people that are
just like they were dead broke on
welfare like and they really hustled in
school then it should be for it and I
agree but I'm not saying it should be
for those for those kids I'm just saying
that that wasn't how do you guys feel if
like let's say they do have this money
set apart for the underprivileged but
because of I don't know resources or
connections they're not able to reach
that do you think that money should just
not be used or do you think that's okay
for now other people to come a kind of
game this is like if there's leftover
money I don't think they have a lot of
leftover money cuz uh so when I went to
evac in Salt Lake Community College
after my after I got my financial aid
stuff I would just like look around with
my wandering eyes and I would see all
these random scholarships on the on the
on the wall one would be like future
teacher scholarship I'm gonna be like
person that's passionate about math
scholarship or whatever and I would just
read like what the requirements are and
they're just like all right like a
little 500 word essay about whatever
right then these are obviously for
people that want to be a teacher later
on this can help them with their studies
and then I'm like how many people are
actually writing to these things in the
financial aid office like there's all
these scholarships no one ever applies
so I'm like oh okay so I wrote I went
home that day and I just wrote like five
essays and I got like a grand each
can I just automatically want it that
part I don't personally I don't have
like an issue with that because that's
what those things are therefore you just
have to do a little bit extra work and
then you get scholarships which seems
that's what this girl was doing anyway
cuz she it does say she combined that
but the part that doesn't sit right with
me is that her family has to do this
like legal separation to milk out more
money which is not cool like you could
just keep writing in more applications
for scholarships and do it the right way
mm-hmm why cheat out like the actual
system for people who need it
because fun like I was home-schooled so
like none of this [ __ ] rings a bell your
home college oh no I did do that this is
not very long how long were you home
school the whole time no high school
thanks good sixth grade no wait in high
school almost sixth grade up and then I
wish the American economy Dramatic Arts
and I got scholarships and grants so
wait when were you home school bus
before sixth grade after the sixth grade
and like Oh after sixth grade through
high school I see so when you like when
you had your the haircut thing was that
oh no that was a guy I had a glow up oh
I got you okay so if you're a home
school and you want to play a sport are
you like varsity and pillow fighting I
don't even know adversity it's like it's
like that like that
oh and pillow fighting oh yeah are you
varsity of doing the dishes
oh yeah and cafeteria that's right it's
my kitchen yes right yeah anyway but yes
and now people are looking into this and
they're like hey that's not cool man
rich people already like they got caught
for that recent college admission on
them they're on them
those were [ __ ] ballers though like
real time bomb like the full house
millionaires and [ __ ] that's so
fascinating actually I actually knew
people that were middle just middle
class and then they did this like they
would become dependents of their
grandparents income so then because you
know their grandparents are living off
Social Security or whatever so they can
get a full ride because their parents
really even if they're middle class they
couldn't afford the high like like
traditionary yeah tuition for like you
seasoned [ __ ] like that you know they
learned after reading this story that
now the SATs they have this new adverse
'red adversity score that they are
implementing along with the SAT scores
which means that it's like affirmative
action or so and now this new score will
calculate local poverty poverty rates
and time surrounding an applicant's high
school among 13 other factors that weigh
in background and up upbringing and
local rates of free or reduced lunch
housing stability and educational
that is dumb as [ __ ] so it kind of like
curves it now like it kind of there's a
second curve that they put in pretty
much hold more crime happens around
latekka dress up yeah I mean what the
[ __ ] that is that is such a shitty
[ __ ] it's like hey guess what
like we're gonna curve it you guys have
more gunshot so you get a score Jesus
man well it does make sense because I
think there's new research out that with
problems at the home and stressors you
tend to score or less in IQ and all
kinds of other stuff so they say that
resilience should be factored into a lot
of these students who cannot perform a
pluses but in the in the spectrum of
life what they have to do to get that
b-plus is a lot more than the kid that
comes from the suburbs that can get a
b-plus that's usually in the personal
statement though yeah I mean so that's
that's hard to quantify obviously but
like cuz you could be kind of like
giving somebody an easy pass but that is
one of the things that they're trying to
factor into the system I like that well
yeah that sounds better right but but
it's still it's still an issue of like
okay so you have a bunch of kids who are
taking a test in one area and a bunch of
kids are taking this exact same test
another area and these kids are gonna
get great easier than these kids because
I've done shots going on it is what that
is well yeah I guess so they're saying
that the first you're gonna have your
regular SAT score and then people that
are cutting it kind of close in to
getting into a college or university or
whatever that's when they're gonna look
at the adversity score and then that
even again I think there should be a
transition so like let's say people that
do get hand-picked from the adverse the
adversity score they're kind of being
set up for failure because they're not
gonna be able to compete with the
Harvard level kids right so two there
should be a transition school that helps
them get up to par and pull them away
from the stressors see that's time I
agree with that
then not a [ __ ] at Harvard
[ __ ] getting nailed yeah yeah I don't
yeah I think it should be out of equal
platform at some point yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]